[Music]
let's talk about the movie Man on a
Ledge which I got to see the other night
and I really enjoyed and a terrific film
the band is instruments falling over
okay
I'm just curious this was a first-time
director that he worked with on this
yeah he had directed a bunch of
documentaries in the past but he had
never directed actors you know he's used
to sort of turning a camera on and just
sort of you know laying back and seeing
what happens yeah and so I happen to be
the very first shot of the movie that we
did I wake at the beginning this movie I
wake up in bed in my undies and I'm very
hungover I've had a little crazy night
Loren Corley does your wife remember
[Laughter]
rewinding and so I'm in the bed and I'm
laying there and you know the directors
at the monitor and he's like like a
little kid in the candy store you know
it's his first big movie and we're you
know it's great and and they're like
okay the cameras rolling sound is
speeding and he's like and I'm just
laying in the bed and you know I have my
eyes closed I'm supposed to be
pretending that I'm asleep right so
after about four and a half minutes I go
are you gonna call action you never
called action you never called action
you know you knew that little about
making sweet and of course we ended up
making fun of him for the rest of the
moviemaking experience but ultimately we
ended up with man on the ledge yeah well
it's a it's hard to summarize something
he's got it's a very unusual plot which
I liked very much but basically the
movie opens with the hero yes out on a
Ledge there's a man on a Ledge man'll a
promise to play the NYPD negotiator
tasked with figuring out why is out
there and trying to get them in hasta
ledge right and and you know and then it
unfolds from there because you think one
thing is happening but really something
else is happening yes you think it's a
straight-ahead story of your job as just
talk him off the ledge and then there's
this whole other story that goes on it's
very cool we have a clip here and I
believe obviously this is when Sam is
out on the ledge and you've been trying
desperately for a long time to get him
to come in
and I believe this is when you decide to
take matters into your own hands this is
sort of a moment I'm trying to make have
a connection with him that so he'll
believe in me all right let's take a
look at this clip from man on the ledge
Mercer
tacticals go the window she'll call down
Mercer
he will go over before he gets taken
down that's assuming our track records
on par with yours phone call says we
clear everybody
but the negotiator no one has found a
bomb this Brett is a star he's playing
you picked you because you're in no
condition to do your job this is my seat
nobody put on Lydia come on clear the
window what are you doing
and you were all away it's Sam was
saying that you he was here and he was
telling us that that's not you in a
studio with green screen which is how I
would demand it be shot were I in the
film that's really you on a Ledge yeah
we were 200 feet above above Madison
Avenue on 14 inches of concrete just
held up there by like shoestring wires
in a harness yeah which by the way I
know was more comfortable for me than it
was for Sam because it's a whole
undercarriage it's a thing that goes
under and for a man yeah but and then
man and then I'm just making noises now
which is what I do